everybody hanomag here your pal
Anna Mac for anime uproar and welcome to
another episode of rent cafe in which
we're gonna be the scariest moments in
anime so what I mean by that is I don't
watch much horror so it can be a horror
genre but it could also be just scary
moments in any genre of anime that we
really thought were and you guys in the
chat thought were standout sort of scary
moments too tightly it could be even
funny stuff such as you know recon
watching a harem anime and then
realizing there's no itchy like that
type of scary stuff that's okay too
we're gonna be talking about all of it
having fun joining me today an old face
by which I mean he's aging horribly
Makela what's up man welcome back hey I
take that as a compliment thank you
though thank you it's been I've missed
this I've missed this I've cried about
this at night so I am so happy to be
back good to see you man Mac has been
busy with work and stuff so he hasn't
been able to come but he's here now we
also have knucks - aku what's up man
nothing much great to be here once again
saving the party tis rican ain't here
unfortunately so i'll have to fight with
you i guess yeah
recon canceled on us last minute Oh for
some obligations also Tony - black
Kritika is supposed to be here I don't
know what's taking him hopefully he
shows up but he is supposed to be here
another old face our friend Tony who now
lives in the Pacific island somewhere he
just heard that I was coming anything at
home that's it could be it could be
because of you guys you guys have that
bromance but then after he moved away to
a random Pacific island where he still
watches movies and reviews them now just
hang on in the bromance suffered but
it's okay we're here we're still rollin
as always by the way last week we had an
after-party in the discord a voice chat
after-party where we hung out with some
of you guys and I was a lot of fun so if
you want to join us for that we'll do
that again this week in voice chat we're
gonna be chatting on discord link in the
description if you wanna join us
in the chat welcome let me know some of
the scariest moments in anime for you
and yes memes and jokes are okay - I'll
NOx or Mac who wants to start with some
scary moments that you remember in anime
that really spoke to you or stuck with
you
so I would like to mention that I don't
find horror anime scary for the most
part I never liked the genre because I
just don't get even another or Higurashi
which are considered like the top to
your horror anime I don't find them
scary so what I consider a good horror
scene would be when I'm watching an
anime episode and it ends with like sort
of a cliffhanger I guess we're after the
ending theme ends I'm still like staring
at the blank screen like holy crap that
just happened like something more like
that because I've never like I just ran
away and stuff like that that didn't
happen yeah I agree like personally I'm
not a big fan of horror anime or a
horror genre in general and I'll tell
you guys why it's because I feel like a
lot of horror is just very basic
formulaic stuff so it's like quiet eerie
music building up to like a shock Val
nose and you're like oh do or like you
know really gory stuff like when you go
to a haunted house and the whole thing
is just like it's dark and then they
suddenly surprise you with a loud noise
and psycho scary it's like that's not
very well you're from Niagara right
yes isn't the Fear Factory there yeah
there's a lot of touristy like haunted
houses stuff and I've been and basically
it's all like dark and then they just
surprise you with loud noises and [ __ ]
well that's basically another and
Higurashi except it's a little girl
getting her brains blown everywhere
every few episodes awesome sounds lovely
Oh Mac you were gonna say something yeah
no yeah just on the on the topic of I
guess jump scares being kind of a cheap
scare 100% agree they make me mad
because they scared the [ __ ] out of me
and that
that for being scared of something so
silly but that's kind of what I liked
about another which was kind of tough to
get into because it it kind of drags for
like five or six episodes but it did a
really good job I guess kind of keeping
me on edge and like feeling sort of
uneasy without the jump scares I don't
think I got jump scared in that [ __ ]
once but it still kind of did a good job
of uh umbrellas through the throat and
it's like all right now's a Best Fiend
advice on which are we talking another
it's the go-to horror anime uh-huh okay
did not see that but we raise this is in
the house by the way guys I haven't seen
him in a while welcome my friend anime
do Kizer trigger is all talking about
how he doesn't give a [ __ ] about horror
he goes to sleep watching horror he's
down much what tough guy I hate horror
exactly and lunch and brunch cuz tough
guys have brunch remember super so you
know he's a tough dude you gotta respect
that even lately been watching tractable
super I have not
I've not stoop to that level yet I was
considering starting but I didn't
actually start yet Jonathan Essex says
when freezer killed Crillon was a scary
moment Marcus how many times did he kill
Crellin only once right no but listen
what's scary if you're a kid watching it
if you're a kid watching it and it's
like all the sudden freezer kills
Crillon you at that point
Krillin only came back to life like five
times until here maybe he's not going to
this time no he didn't come back to life
before that that many times if at all I
don't know well other characters did
this is Dragonball Z of frieza saga
right so so yeah like I definitely
remember when I was small watching
journals he for his own cousin aired in
like the late 90s early 2000 early 2000s
in the West even though it's from like
the 80s in Japan and when I watched like
Frieza just having that creepy female
voice like an old grandmother but like
he's evil and I'm genocide maniac I
thought yeah
time obviously now it's much different
but still yeah that's another question
in terms of what we find scary at
certain points in our lives but so yeah
so not a big fan of the horror genre
because I feel like a lot of it is
cliche however there are certain things
in the horror genre that I do enjoy and
such as stranger things if you guys
watch change of things because I feel
like that show is not just horror it's
like the game of thrones or horror like
it's a different league
so I do enjoy something like that but
I've never been really too much into
anime horror or horror in general myself
like I'll watch something here they're
like you know the jaws movies some stuff
like that jaws saw I mean suck ups like
jaws like mastiff or like brought up in
cowboy bebop the piano Lefou episode
which is yeah like sometimes anime
especially episodic anime sometimes
they'll throw it in an episode it's just
like a kind of a curveball and Dowlen
definitely that is I would say creepy
like that Piero guy was definitely
creepy that the fat clown dude the Hat
yeah yeah right
I know the right another difference with
horror in terms of Japanese [ __ ] it's
often much more psychological than
Western gore type or so you know the
scary movies and anime in Japan are kind
of more cyclone forefathers theory like
stuff is a you know mass murderers and
stuff like that but I did it one thing
that I remember you guys seen it
fate/zero right yeah first 40 minutes
what they're walking in a circle
oh my I'm sorry I couldn't do it they're
just like yours they're walking in a
circle they're like here's your
connection or something yeah I'm at like
your that your mic is like
addict I don't know if it's your mic or
like your maybe it's you it might be
your mustache
well his image seems fine so like okay
well we'll see well right yes so in
reesy row while Mac reason our fate/zero
you said fade zero before yeah fade zero
sorry I thought a part it was scary to
me was that freaking burn it ass
murderer though that guy his sermon is
caster right right huh
and remember when he kills that boy's
family and then he kills the boy I was
like wow I was like this is oh [ __ ]
hate this dude mandus one thing about
him he ended up having that whole debate
with caster about how God really wants
him to kill people yeah do you remember
that
yeah like vaguely okay so you have to go
watch fade zero again am I gonna be
watched every five months man the point
is I thought that them two together
killing people was scary it wasn't just
like I thought the scary part was that
their mindset was that it's it's good
they're doing good deeds by being
horrible and it's that perverted mindset
then I found creepy rather than their
actions because you know there are
plenty psychos and anime I mean that's
where psychos thrive your average bad
guy is just evil for the sake of wanting
to kill people yeah yeah youself I know
Mac may I agree with you Knox like it
was like a psychological type of horror
because it wasn't like oh this guy you
know he kills people it's blood
everywhere and it's like Oh like yeah
you mentioned re0 also so I mentioned
accidentally but I do think that there
are horror elements to read zero my
favorite scene in the whole show that
got me like invested in the series and I
still think it's like the creepiest
moment was I think it was the end of
episode 3 he gets to the mansion and he
lives his first day in the hole in the
mansion with RAM and RAM and Amelia and
really creepy
what's his name the clown guy he has the
greatest voice actor ever by the way no
subs you plebs
is it yeah probably I don't know and
he's voice acted by Diaz voice actor to
which just makes it even better and bit
but by the end of that episode like he
goes to sleep in the butler
you know pajamas and he wakes up and
he's not wearing those clothes and he's
like looking around and he's wondering
why is he in this position and the
episode ends with you understanding that
he died and it just reset and he has no
idea why he died yes really creepy yes
yeah that music that's good it's just
like random Stubbs a girl that was like
a chilling scene yeah Reiser is
interesting and I'll pass it to you Mac
after because I know you've seen re0 as
well but Reiser is interesting because
it has many elements so it has like you
do your classic isa Kai fantasy element
which is not necessarily connected to
horror at all
it's got your romance harem element
obviously which messes you know not
something you necessarily associate with
horror and yeah I would argue that
rezero has a lot of horror elements
starting with you know the first episode
arc when Elsa just brutally murder Sam
and Amelia and then and then after that
when we go to the mansion it so for a
bit it's a little more lighthearted but
then like knocks like you said he keeps
dying he doesn't know what the hell's
going on then later on when he's trying
to like make it back before the witch
cult attacks and then he doesn't make it
back and everyone dies and all this [ __ ]
and RAM gets tortured like I was like
this is some horror stuff just becomes
like totally insane yeah exactly like he
just show progression that's why I mean
as a person I didn't like Subaru or his
personality but they
character progression was great yeah my
problem was not animated when I was
watching it's like I wasn't going into
it thinking we're gonna watch a horror
anime let's think there's gonna be a
fantasy yokai romance and then these you
know sometimes like I was like what the
hell is going on like these told shits
man I'd consider it more of a mature
fantasy than a horror
yes but regularly as for goal wasn't to
scare you it was it at times I think at
least psychologically kind of like cuz
they say what you want but Beto goose is
a scary [ __ ] that was gonna be my point
I like meant like hiding himself you had
Mack go ahead
yo just gonna say him biting himself was
like I still think about it sometimes
and I'm thinking about it now and it
really uncomfortable that for me that
right there you know I like him nobody I
don't know he's not just like creepy is
like violently into saying like he is
[ __ ] that's wonderful I would always
prefer an anime villain who's killing
people for the sake of killing people
but totally insane then someone who
makes believe he's normal but just goes
out and rampages killing people cuz this
guy he's not you understand that yeah
well it depends it depends because you
can have a villain that's not nuts but
still interesting like I don't know
vicious from Cowboy Bebop
stuff like that but he's not evil for
the sake of being evil and killing and
the fun of killing yeah well neither is
bethel goose he thinks he's he's working
for the witch Yeah right that's why i
think he was a pretty decent villain he
was a not a bad villain at all no yeah
he's an interest to cure if he's
completely [ __ ] insane and everything
he says is like you're you're [ __ ] but
that's wonderful
my brain is trembling and then he can't
die because he has all these like
[ __ ] host bodies it's like man just
[ __ ] kill him and someone doing that
so I was like man to kill beggars please
and then he becomes a spider what the
[ __ ] was that and then he killed him
with a death note means
yeah yeah three zero has its moments
sure like that yeah [ __ ] moments um well
my favorite comment so far has to be
Josh Duffy saying talking about scariest
moments in anime when you find out your
suit is really dark midnight blue and
not black
that is nightmarish neo yoki oh joke
guys
good work I'm a cousin that's colorblind
so when he went to get a suit he brought
his brother along to get the suit and he
ended up buying some bright orange suit
and he thought it was like dark beige or
something
yeah you brought it to the real world
bro oh we're talking me okie oh you know
my favorite comment I think it was the
anime dude that said it he said that
Courage the Cowardly Dog is his scariest
anime anime dude honest roll ish
trollers comments any of you watch that
ever okay I've heard of it but I don't
think I've actually seen on that because
I think that was like a Cartoon Network
show right yeah yeah your loss
the manga was great too yeah I'm sure it
was I saw someone in jet mention your
next eight seals I mean that was pretty
terrifying for what it's worth but I saw
someone mentioned corpse parted pretty
early on the game obviously was like
really creepy but they did like it I
don't know if any of you have seen it
it's like a three Episode OVA series I
have not seen it man it's it's
definitely if you care about like
staying true to the source material or
whatever it's not but it's a it's got
some pretty brutal moments like there is
a dead man wonderland oh yeah like we're
talking like you see tongues getting
like cut out with scissors you see like
scissors going into the I like it's it's
uncomfortable sometimes more stuffing
yeah yeah which I'm not a usually a huge
fan of like you just kind of makes me
sick but it's a it made me feel things
which was mostly holy [ __ ] and if anime
can make me feel things and that's
that's great I convinced my sister to
watch it by telling her it was like
universe and she wasn't it's not it's
not no it's nothing like it she wasn't
she wasn't stoked but that's that's good
for anyone who likes like but if that's
your thing then pretty short well
another anime that I found scary in a
thriller way was erased yeah yeah there
were some cliffhanger endings that were
just like holy crap what happened like
after his whole plan works and I think
her name was kayo and he finally saves
her and everything's going well he goes
to school the next day and the teacher
said oh there's so oh you're here so
there's only one absence only caios
missing and he's like oh what what just
happened every every episode for that
show I was like see that's the type that
there's two type of cliffhangers there's
the type that's like so it could just
like hit you like a train and then
there's oh come on why are you stopping
middle fight you you piece of crap
kids exactly there's what the [ __ ] and
then there's what the [ __ ] exactly so
there is did another one I saw the
comment section was the anime man asked
this parasite wasn't really scary about
what it count as a horror well you don't
have we don't have to talk about horror
here like I said I don't watch that much
for her so I can't really you know just
our hora but if you there's plenty of
scary moments in like of course the
freaking Nina
Tucker's seen in Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood house amazing that was scary
and sad and freakin creepy and [ __ ] you
sho talker [ __ ] you so yeah that's an
example of some some kind of right but I
found an even creepier scene than that
in was I mean we could spoil this right
everyone's watched it right sure
scariest scene was okay
maybe next time they are they just said
choreographer
you could mute it you know if you want
but I'm back one back great so I think
the creepiest scene was where Envy was
just walking up to the booth where
Hughes was bleeding out the phone booth
and he transforms into his wife and he
can't shoot her it's like you know it's
coming and she was like the greatest
character ever that was so sad that was
like the moment in the show that got me
kind of hooked on it though like I I
watched it like midseason that no
clothes was going on that was the first
anime ever watched period and then after
that I was like oh man this is sweet and
I got back home from vacation then
summer and I bought it on Amazon for
like 40 bucks but that's that's
interesting it's like it's like a moral
dilemma right because like II know it's
not really his wife but it's like it's
so against your instinct to shoot
someone who looks like but like your
wife right so it's more than a moral
dilemma it's it's like you know a
two-second shock value yeah it's like it
is it's like a universal sort of human
dilemma of like playing on human
emotions and attachments right which is
why full Marcus Brotherhood is not your
average Shonen right it's so much deeper
and such a great anime overall um um who
asks where is Tony ask Tony where he is
because he said he would come this week
I sent him the link and he's not
responding so on boo you can take that
up with Tony tony's tony's in flake town
he's at the flake party because he's up
like he's playing it up you're right
over there
Tony flakes there Sora senpai yeah like
one the scariest thing about no game no
life was how much it insulted my
intelligence I was that was definitely
scary to think that all these people
have everything figured out 18 moves
ahead of everyone oh and why do I look
at all this contrived fanservice
Oh scary stuff man don't don't don't
overplay it
well one thing about the chat this time
everyone is sarcastic so everyone
watching go subscribe to me yeah yeah
all 35 of y'all by the way Nux link in
the description Mac link in the
description also Tony's like in the
description because I was expecting him
but he's not here so it may be yeah
subscribe him later but yeah we have
some Nina comments Neen Einstein from
Cole Diaz yeah she's she has her like
Subaru losing his mind moment say like
her face and Subaru face at certain
times when they're just like losing
their [ __ ] definitely recommend Minds me
want one of the other for sure
I remember blood see had a moment where
this giant monster thing was basically
just going on a rampage snagging up
random people and I remember
specifically wanting to throw up when
there were two friends one of them ran
away he grabbed one just kind of bashed
her left to right on the pavement took
the other one like he's a big guy like
we're talking like I'm the monster this
is the person right there goes the
person but rip the legs down the middle
and like I I almost I almost it was
almost been there was almost in this do
you recommend there you've missed read
that Haruki figurine that that's a
horror [ __ ] right there for a figurine
collector figurines are scary I am -
shame - yeah I don't personally get the
whole figurine thing but goals in has
bought a bunch of them so not we have a
bunch it's that's the collector value
you have them you put them on your desk
they look at you make you believe you
make you think you have company exactly
exactly we all know we don't have
friends so like why not have fake ones
well now I am animatic I think you're
becoming a real classy we've now with
you and your figurines look she's even
doing the two-finger thing yeah so we I
think she's having you dabbing
no she's not oh I didn't I didn't clue
in what the two-finger thing was a tres
like yeah yeah okay now and now I get it
well so another thing about car anime
very often it's some body modification
and they are just lumping in the horror
genre just because oh my god there was a
person and now it's something else like
parasite well there were scary scenes in
parasites so I do sort of see why it
would be called a har and there were
some creepy moments in parasite because
these treatment you guys watch parasite
right I haven't no watched anything good
have you oh god what draggable super
super doesn't that real weird [ __ ]
creepy aliens man yeah it does yeah now
not weird creepy aliens of Dragon Ball
super we're literally three-quarters of
the cast is creepy aliens fine you got
me no well I saw the trailer for
parasite I was like this looks creepy as
[ __ ] so that's no I
crunchyroll made the worst trailer for
it of all time
like literally I I watched the trailer
when I was halfway through the show and
I was like holy crap I'm not watching it
yeah that's what I stated ugh I told my
brother to watch parasite he says okay
and he's watching some YouTube video and
he gets a crunchyroll ad for parasite
he's like you told me to watch this I'm
not watching this okay so okay so now
you're telling me that the trailer was
not good because now I'm thinking of me
crap and it's misleading okay okay
because yeah when I saw the trailer I
was like what the [ __ ] is this but you
know he's mine torture amazing series
okay okay fine I will I will take your
word for it knocks you haven't failed me
before so I will believe in you well you
haven't tried Jojo so you don't know yet
oh yeah elf and lead the anime dude
brought up elf and leave great great
anime again could be considered horror
for sure probably is and yet I loved it
even though I'm not a fan of horror
because it's just overall a good MV but
definitely a lot of gore a lot of
psychological stuff a lot of real you
know a character that does horrible
things and
the writing still gets you to relate to
that character and kind of understand
where they're coming from which i think
is brilliant it's not just like a oh
look at this character did horrible
things because they're a villain and
they're bad and we hate them and we hope
they die it's kind of like like I like
this character even though she did
horrible things because so much things
so much happened during her life and
it's like ah it's a good anime it's a
good animal anyway I kind of went on a
tangent guys they have like this really
traumatic
you know puppy scene right yes that's
just one of the scene it's like the
saddest thing in the world then I'm
thinking myself holy crap they just
killed dozens of people hundreds of
people are dying everywhere and I'm
feeling terrible about this puppy not
it's normal man people I don't care I'm
a normal person so I felt worse about
the sister and fall other but Mac people
are pretty shitty so I mean I get it
when yeah and when the puppy puppies are
the soft spot I always I always joke
with my friend Tony not the black credit
guy the other Tony and I know one of two
let's say all right yeah yeah the white
Tony we'll go with white Tony yeah the
one - you go up if you invited him
exactly yeah
he's a good guy by the way for everyone
that dropped out last second all three
of you people know well recon drop the
last second and apparently Tony but Sol
couldn't make it either work they just
don't want any that was common to people
screwed us
but yes Mac continued I told I totally
forget what I was saying I was just shot
the three people didn't show up
oh yeah puppies it's gone man people can
be evil or something but you know these
are bad dogs are good did any of you see
school live by chance
no lion why gakkou gurashi sure yeah the
one with the one
utin mo a and it's in school and
everything is beautiful and all of a
sudden zombie apocalypse yeah that one
that one spoiler alert for anyone who
hasn't seen that one yeah that's the dog
I felt so bad about the dog I didn't
care about anybody else dying I was like
woohoo that's that's so bad they died
when the dog died was just ugly cry so
yeah Mina when me and i got fused with
the pup whatever his name was the dog
all the poor dog Oh exactly exactly and
then when like then wasn't like anyone
else dies in the shower like oh okay
well you moved a good life
[Music]
well here's the thing here's why I think
the dog stuff like speaks to people it's
like you're watching an anime where the
main characters you know are going to be
human and if it's an action anime or
whatever you're expecting people to die
it's part of it like you're coming into
it without expectation but then when
like a dog guys which isn't necessary
because you know a dog is not anyone's
enemy is just collateral damage then
you're like oh [ __ ] you know now this is
real now this is getting real this is
real now by the way someone said avatar
is an anime in order to horrify us you
should go and chill with Jeff from
mother's basement I still have
nightmares about that video he made you
can you can come chill with me too it
sounds like no I did I saw I read the
title I got the gist but this makes
sense in a context of a previous
discussion but yes be family yeah go on
so um basically the way I see it is in
Japan the word anime means an animation
so according to them family guys in
anime just like avatars in anime just
like Naruto's an anime so if it's
animated it's an anime according to
Japanese
yes we're using a Japanese term anime to
refer to Japanese animation otherwise
again you know if avatars and animations
so is family guy in scooby-doo and Tom
and Jerry I think I think every the only
people
get upset over calling cartoons anime or
everybody but the Japanese I don't even
think they care they're probably like
we're doing fine over here we're good
we're buying call whatever you want man
yeah they probably don't care but it is
useful crap it is useful to have a kind
of differentiation because there is a
difference between Western cartoons and
anime in terms of you know the style
these far as culture the cultural
context and all that stuff and it's uh
it's interesting though because yeah you
said a lot of people say well avatar is
inspired by anime which is true and
avatar deals with a lot of similar
themes that anime deal with salt let's
call it an anime because it's in that
same our style well Neil yo kyo ladies
and gentlemen is also inspired by anime
so you know even Family Guy and that
stuff aside if you say that out there is
an anime you 100% have to say that neo
yo kyo is a legit enemy so you can't
classify anime if it's good or not
that's not a classification there are
plenty crappy anime that I wouldn't say
oh it's a cartoon no it's true it's true
there's plenty of animes like Japanese
anime that are bad that's true but I'm
just saying if you're gonna say that
just because something is influenced by
anime now that should be considered
anime because the anime is just an
artistic movement then if Fallot areas
on animes so is neo yo Kyo so is critic
see the eight seals thankfully guys
I don't consider avatar on anime and
because like I said I think that anime
in the way we use it the term in the
West as it's also a cultural and
historical context Oh Japanese and
roughly um term where it's a semantic
argument but the cloak lleol meaning of
anime over here is talking about Japan
in Japanese animation yeah exactly so
it's like it's a good point that you
made though that like different cultures
are different they use different terms
to refer to different things so it's
like a word might mean something a bit
different here than in China or Japan
something to think about but I
definitely think that it's useful to
have anime as a category so you know we
have crunchy
roll for anime we don't have Pez Ruby
which is not anime well that's [ __ ]
they shouldn't just wrong men yeah well
yeah might as well have cory in the
house on crunchyroll then and i mean i'm
on a chat right now Todoroki Shoko said
and my caller stay poppin that is scary
crap right there jay park my colors stay
Pippen whatever that means but I get I
get what he's saying what's up Lucario
and yeah cory in the house best anime
people are saying now well yeah it's
true if everybody's on the crap is
animated and so is Cornelison again
nothing wrong without action though good
luck on that no you know it's Nana me
shut up said you've got it wrong in the
challenge yeah yeah but no I definitely
enjoyed avatar I even enjoyed new yo Kyo
I made a whole video about it but like
the thing is just because I enjoy
doesn't mean it I think it's necessarily
animate guys um on the topic of scary
anime has anyone either here in chat
heard or seen cheeky so I started cheeky
but I didn't really get into it that's
fair that's fair that's really kind of
tough to get it I feel like most good
like horror anime whatever you want to
classify them as take some the one the
ones that really stick with you take
some time to get into so that's hey that
makes sense it's fine have you um have
you tried a hell girl no I haven't tried
hell girl yet that's a creepy anime it's
about uh basically people can access a
certain website at like a certain time
if they have a grudge against someone
they can basically go kill them by
signing up this hell girl to go take
them out I mean that's the basic gist
yeah so it's like dark web meets anime
except they're not looking at memes
they're killing
that's cool great analogy that's what we
need a we need a we need a dank meme it
is something based solely around their
not even not even means but the creation
of memes like people who that's their
sole purpose is to create dank memes
they fight each other with the power of
dank memes and friendship doesn't fuel
them only with day yeah it's called
idubbbz in filthy Frank there you go
yeah and someone someone makes a miso
tank it begins to kill people solve the
mystery of the day it's very scary
scariest YouTube video of the year was
content cop on rice gum that's good it
was entertaining you gotta know about
scary scared dry scum what by the way
both ways gaming asked me if I watched
nan Baca after the challenge with Knux
no I have not I don't even know what nan
Baca is no one wants me before so yeah I
would say it's similar very similar in
humor style I guess to Gintama sort of
but you haven't watched that either no
you steered clear from the good stuff
yeah you have to stay with a clear mind
to watch Dragon Ball super yeah exactly
man Dragon Ball super and all that one
piece oh wait your [ __ ] image one
piece fanboy shut up who you you you're
a huge fan boy I like this you grab one
piece you love one piece you can't stop
too although one piece and nothing
against one piece I'm just saying a lot
of people say about one piece why you
say about durable super just because
they're oh it's mainstream it's crap
filler etc one major difference between
the two is that one piece is actually
really good unlike Dragon Ball super and
Dragon Ball Z quite frankly is not in
the same league as one piece but it's
not what keeps my attention all day well
I don't a lot of people have crap to
throw at JoJo's have you even watched
Super ever
how many episodes we talking like more
than two yes I watched four okay I've
been waiting to show this one - that
goes in God that is the outfit our girl
Arturia has when Madea hazard when Anna
Mac can't think of scary anime show this
to all the faint fanboys which I think
includes an ox you know he doesn't want
to admit it yeah well well this is from
faves here isn't it I think I don't
anyway doesn't matter the point is you
guys made me think of two other anime
that I not horror but I thought there
was a lot of scary moments in them scary
/ creepy uncanny one of them is
gunslinger girl because I thought the
whole concept of you know girls being
bred to become deadly assassins was very
like scary psychologically kind of you
know um just disturbing to see the whole
idea and also Psychopaths has that I
thought were very scary like with the
whole shogo makishima show go and like
his the mass killings happening and like
people like just like hitting each other
like and without any like ounce of
humanity because of their their
completely lost in the technology and
the whole psyche concept rape all
Psychopaths
thank you finally you praised me I
praise you I praise you I didn't think
of it I haven't seen Psychopaths yet but
when my old roommates was super into it
I really should yeah like I don't know
this is it's something I like about
quino's journey also it's so you take a
society you give it different rules and
then they develop a whole play out for
that society and Psychopaths does that
so well because even in the society it
had and the weird dystopian future it
was taking place in there was a twist in
that you know actual universe as well
when a fantasy or a dystopian future or
whatever is written it sort of stays in
that theme throughout you know we're in
a cool fantasy world we're gonna abuse
what this fantasy world does but the
writer for Psychopaths again who Tabuchi
he is famous for setting up a great
fantasy setting or whatever or sci-fi
and still making it have a full 180 plot
twist halfway through he did it with
Madoka Magica also and that's why that's
why fate 0 was so good cuz he he wrote
fate/zero it which made it sir ya could
say what you're saying oh no I'm just
gonna say sup I said original there's no
source of like that's that's it or is it
their source material - I believe it's
their an original anime I don't I
haven't read the manga and yeah
especially the first season will we are
really good the second season is kind of
like so I'm one of them I'm one of the
weird guys that actually really liked
the second season - I didn't mind the
second season but he was almost like
unnecessary kind of thing I don't know
if you know what I mean well it sort of
was it was you know a bit of a cash grab
but I enjoyed it feel like it was adding
anything to the story necessarily even
though I didn't hate it I still got
through it and still had some of the
magic y-you know you know some of the
characters were not there you know which
ones I mean so yeah it was odd right I
liked the villain though so he sort of
pulled it through and they gave him the
edgiest name ever it was right after in
Naruto Shippuden it was right after
Obito was revealed to be using Kamui the
entire time and it was right after
sorted online so they named him Kamui
cutie toe so I was like oh my god this
is the greatest anime ever yeah they in
Psychopaths they have a lot of direct
references their reference like William
Gibson philip k dick russo my favorite
philosopher like it's crazy they they
really have a lot of men are moments i
like it and i love the way they start
Psychopaths
they started with like the whole online
world where it seems very friendly and
like kind of like
where our world is heading it's very
feels very real in terms of where our
world is heading and easy [ __ ] laughing
yeah yeah I praise You Man I praise you
for mentioning it but there were two
that I thought of that I really wanted
to talk about while we were talking
about this one
so the first ones monster have any of
you seen monster yeah in a while but I
know it's like a it's like one of those
that's like the pacing is not too fast
however this however it keeps you
thrilled throughout yeah
74 episodes I believe and it was
phenomenal
it goes ins a big fan from the villain
to the progression of the protagonist
like the whole thing and there it had
plenty of scary moments as well
throughout yeah and they're like just
unraveling it scary but not in like a
cheap way right no in a you know an
authentic psychological scary setting
that you understand the main villain so
well you know and even the protagonist
has to sort of fall into villainy too
you know as as a great role model of
mine says you can't fix the whole world
without getting your hands dirty is your
role model
maybe so yeah so I wanted to mention
monster not named after the energy drink
I watched the monster energy drink
animate it wish don't even watch it rock
star was better the rock star out of a
boy I should have left in the Red Bull
the Red Bull one was nothing like the
manga but go ahead and knocks the second
and the second one I really wanted to
talk about was berserk Berserker horror
I would consider Berserker because the
final episode of berserk scared the
living crap out of me I haven't seen
berserk or read the manga so I can't
speak to it but I've had heard good
things it's kind
like jojo's in terms of has really like
hardcore fans well it's not like judges
and all cuz like not at all at all at
all and all the fanbase the fanbase like
the fan right because one thing about
the berserk fanbase
they'll they're quiet about it people
can love berserk but it's not like
everywhere it's not like they're gonna
walk down the street and then just pose
randomly and yell you know something
like that
that's a Joe Joe fan type right well
that's you that's not everyone that's
you know it's everyone when I see a
fellow Joe Joe fan in the street we both
you know pose and and yell things at
each other this is why I judge is
amazing you just you have to get into it
also on the first 10 episodes are slow
so it's a shame but um I was actually on
a podcast and of someone else on ana
Bridger podcast and phasic you cheated
and basic baby bro
and basically I'm kidding and basically
Joe Joe came up and he was like oh my
god Joe Joe's my favorite anime 10 into
10 it's perfect I was like oh I need you
for an cafe no but no I'm don't worry so
the thing about berserk the anime the 25
episode anime is basically a prologue to
the actual story in the manga the whole
anime just because do you know the genre
is for berserk I mean you know what it's
anything about it yeah it's like a war
right right so you say fantasy war you
only see that in like pretty much the
final episode of the anime I'm talking
1997 enemy I'm not talking about 2016 3
I know I know how much people hate the
new the Reata its guts and whatever but
yeah so the tone shift at the end at the
final episode of berserk was
unbelievable it just went
from you know noble knights and wars
between people to just holy crap this is
the world they're living in holy crap
there's a lot of dead people everywhere
and I don't know need to spoil it you
should just watch it how many episodes
the original 25 I always assume berserk
was like this like 200 episode anime
based on how much there is 25 episodes
the animation is bad but the pace is
decent and that's like the first hundred
chapters of the manga which goes to
about three something you but the
animation of the old one is still better
than the new one apparently well the new
one just well they mixed up the plot
also in the new one and at least it's
the old one sort of stuck with the
source material
did did anyway since that guy Yuri
shinsekai ordered no I don't think so
unless it has a different anything
shin sekai or he doesn't have another
name I'm sure it has an English name
something new world yeah from the new
world it's called from the new world oh
no I have not seen it have you heard of
it no I'm never even heard of it I'm so
glad we're doing this that is a
phenomenal anime it's based off a novel
not a light novel so it's not like you
know the teen angst anime it's based off
a novel it's a mature story where all of
a sudden everyone break well not
everyone 0.1% of the population
developed this weird psychokinesis
godlike power and many years later the
story takes place between whatever I
don't want to ruin it I can't what is it
it's a great series wonderful series
alright so guys pens and papers everyone
parasite shin sekai ori and everything
else you know so every anime i had its
the anime dude end of chat said was high
school of the bed scary
I think it definitely has scary elements
but primarily I think it's an action
comedy yeah and that being Gary's arc
High School of the Dead was pedantic
romantic video and I know who that is
now this is good this is good
yeah the feminism moving on Nayeem muadh
Nayeem asked me if I think Tokyo ghoul
is scary no I do not think Tokyo ghoul
is scary I just thought it was
frustrating and stupid
it was gore for the sake of gore
edginess for the sake of edginess
cannibal porn disliked it zero two out
of ten yeah alright so I got a lot of
people with pissed with Tokyo ghoul I
understand to say it's not scary though
isn't I can't a hundred percent agree
with you sometimes yeah it's just like
oh that's blood that's there for the
sake of blood but it kind of depends on
what makes you tick right like for me I
can't do torture I can't take like like
I guess again process like people just
like hurting other people and that
person can't do anything about it
so when when the man mister connect II
can was chained to a chair having his
toes ripped off over and over and over
again that made me cringe like I
couldn't like I thought about it when I
went to sleep that night like it's like
that that's like my worst fear if I was
in that situation I'd be like okay just
you can kill me and that would be way
better or no I cannot
what's a thousand minus seven okay
thankfully I am glad I don't know what
the [ __ ] you guys are talking about
because so so stupid like every like Mac
I understand that you three person
couldn't you know that scene you found
scary but like it's just edginess for
the sake of edges every edgy team show
has torture porn scenes Vampire Diaries
you name it like they all have those
types of torture porn scenes because
it's just a new edgy thing that people
teens enjoy these dates yeah I enjoy it
though Google wasn't a bad anime it just
I don't think well you know hype - anime
you never know what it's gonna be
and as far as the height monsters Tokyo
ghoul is one of my least favorite like I
preferred sorta online - Tokyo ghoul why
absolutely did yes
I would watch if you told me you can
choose to watch sort online or Tokyo
ghoul
I would like give me my cutie toe you
just you turn into recon like a looter
Natori kind of like yes I get to see
Asuna and the swords and chignon and of
the other girls whose names I forget
yeah oh I think there was a lot of good
it wasn't perfect
based on I'm like what the was in my
opinion never happened so we'll just say
it like that there was no second season
- Tokyo ghoul as far as the first season
I think the final fight Jason versus
kanaky was one of my favorite fights
ever and one of the best rape scenes in
anime probably that's the whole thing
it's all about cannibal rape it's so
[ __ ] stupid
why the dad may guy not get killed by
toca why does he come back to life
because but I mean obviously rear a
tional II she would have had to have
killed him in that scene because of his
behavior if she wanted to save kaneki
she would have had to finish him why
would she not finish him off it is so
stupid it is so freaking I get you
though I get you like it's I'm not I'm
not gonna argue with you
it's not a perfect anime by any means
it's probably not even like I guess a
lot of people wouldn't even consider it
good I enjoyed my time with it that's
really all that nice and I don't like
nukes I agree with ducks in the case
that the fight with connecting and Jason
at the ends so satisfy especially when
he starts counting down himself he's
like hey man gets into the floor you
just kill yo what was it was it
- seven mm-hmm that's what the episode
ends and it was just so you know
satisfying the problem I had with Tokyo
ghoul and yet people are like now this
is becoming extreme or why I hate Tokyo
hey you guys brought it up okay
but it was okay yeah for once we're on
topic in this that's just weird
does this we're clearly we need more
people in here otherwise we stay on
topic but the thing is I was hyped up
the anime Mecca when I started watching
it and that intro was awesome with the
unravel song and everything and I'm like
oh man this is gonna be a classic I had
such high expectations like cannibal
porn this is just a GTA this is just a
gteen tumblr cannibal porn like Tokyo
ghoul is the perfect tumblr anime it's
just it's tumblr Deana may quote me on
this quote it's tumblr the anime anime
on Tokyo ghoul 2017 yeah well you didn't
mention attack on Titan yet yes attack
on Titan not a horror anime well I
definitely had eerie scenes definitely
has scary scenes that's interesting that
I didn't mention because I just find it
so such a good action anime that I guess
I in my mind I just put it into action
but absolutely it's just like now I'm
like the world and everything but yeah
like definitely he was just the end of
episode 1 you know that's classy Arsene
you know well I definitely think that
the Titans are zombies like they're
they're zombies what they're know
exactly for the most part dom bees are a
weaker form of person like in the
walking dead
the zombies they suck right yeah but
there's a lot of them so then that's why
they're a threat right but the Titans
every individual Titan is a scary
creature yeah and it's interesting too
because at first you know they have the
walls set up so and all the Titans are
behind the wall so it's like zombies but
Zombies if you already had your you know
a safe area you know and you're keeping
them out you know you fence them out but
then just like with the zombie genre you
realize that anyone in your society
could also be a Titan so it's just like
zombies the whole point of zombies it's
like everyone you know could turn into a
zombie it could become a threat to you
and that's the scary part of it it's not
like necessarily just some faraway
threat it's like everyone around you
could become a threat so that's what
makes the zombie genre so scary and
attack on Titan also goes into that as
well so they're not just behind the
walls anymore so and obviously a lot of
gore but not tasteless gore in my
opinion not like it's called or it's not
like oh here let's just torture Aaron
like there is a torture Aaron scene but
it's not I thought it was funnier than
it was scary if we're think of the same
one oh there is yeah if you're talking
about Levi yes that was that wasn't that
bad but like there's one where he's like
not really tortured but tied up where
it's not like manga yeah in the manga
where everyone has to get tortured at
some point like well yeah an attack on
zombies code the cabin area the iron
fortress right that was good from what I
saw I didn't finish it
wonderful it's an attack on Titan ripoff
made by the same studio it's an original
anime it's like basically they want it
to grab some hype that attack on Titan
got with this and there were definitely
scary scenes here too because these
cabin re guys these zombies they're
effectively zombies like in the walking
dead except it's really hard to kill
them
and you know they whatever one zombie
gets in and the town is screwed Vic
you're [ __ ] that's it enjoy guys so
why would you say it's a clone I know
I've heard a lot of people say this so
I'm just wondering have you seen it
I haven't yet so wit studio until my
hotz gyno Yomi it had one theme because
it started with attack on Titan and
attack in Titan worked great so
basically tried to make
shows run on the similar scale so they
start with a tag on Titan first three
episodes or two episodes are dramatic
the world as we knew it is destroyed and
it's up to our teenagers to basically go
save the day at this point okay
so then they did a more childish
child-friendly one they did a water you
know serif it's around for the end which
is basically the same idea the first
episode the world is destroyed every
adult on the planet dies the kids are
brought into slavery by these vampires
and another basically in our description
big steampunk zombies man that's that's
all I gonna know big trains with a group
of teens get power save the day and then
owari no Seraph is the same thing except
this time it's aam be instead of
vampires or Titans where they live in
these hold off stations and they travel
with these the iron fortress basically
trains these really thick heavy trains
and so the zombies don't get in and
unfortunately the series in the
beginning zombies get onto the train
that enters the city and bye-bye city
well you realize you just know you make
me want to actually watch it though like
it solves it well you can watch it if
you want it's some again like attack of
a man owari no Seraph the beginning is
amazing however it has to maintain it
and it has no manga okay well I
respected not being an original it being
an original then but yeah I'll give it a
shot I'll see what I think because
obviously I'm thorough attack on Titan
guys so I'm gonna see what I think
whether I think it's a ripoff or what
and you're a steam punk yes I'm a big
fan of you [ __ ] I wrote a steampunk
novel exactly get that [ __ ] published
but both base gaming's to talk to talks
about the assassination class from
ending being saturd and the Clannad
after story ending well obviously
because the cannot after story ending is
[ __ ] amazing and not sad at all what
anime are you watching anyways I don't
know why we're talking about
assassination classroom I glad I'm sorry
I appreciate these enough [ __ ] guys
sometimes I guess sad and scary can get
mixed up I guess it's true that's true
but still I say
no way up or-or-or noise scary I think
it was it was a good it was a good
comedy my anime only you will let me see
this an anime type plot that actually
succeeds in like tugging at your heart
strings and bringing out the characters
in a cool way
so definitely a substantial classroom is
one of those anime that I really enjoyed
I was like this looks weird but then I
was pleasantly surprised it was like
more than just pervert weird teacher it
like has a soul it has a soul so I
definitely enjoy that if you're thinking
of watching cabin arey then please watch
shin sekai ori first because it's like
way better like infinitely better i
watched a better one first why would you
watch the better one first good huh
is it kept and airy supposed to be
getting a second season or something or
is that just i think so
well I don't think no I don't think it
was official I think people want a
second season I think a guy I don't
think a lot of people want to say it
sees it apparently I think enough people
I think there was enough hype for it
that it might get a second one but right
but it so quickly because it had such an
anti climactic ending well I heard and
some what some people were saying that
the reason attack on Titan is not
getting produced as fast as it should is
because they're producing a second
season of commentary the same day hope
that's not true before we wrap it up if
you watched danganronpa well it's a
video game but it also got an anime and
is it good so the way it is the first
season is done on robot one and then
there's two more seasons that both aired
at the same exact time and they're both
called dangan ronpa
3 and there are two different timelines
that play out together and the end of
one of the dangan ronpa threes is right
before the beginning of the next dangan
ronpa 3 which is an interesting setup
for the series but do I think it was
good so I haven't played the video game
but from what I hear the video game is
Wade that
what it's about is a bunch of like you
know genius or whatever students end up
getting called to this special school
they go to the special school and it's
like one of those surprise you're
actually an anime school so yeah they
kill each other and but it's set up in a
way that there's only one of you that's
just one of you have to die every half
an hour or whatever or else you all get
knocked out and we decide to kill one of
you and so people don't want that to be
them so they decide to kill each other
and did the people degrade into monsters
a little bit and then every time if saw
was gonna fight no not like that but
instead every time one of them would
every time one student would kill
another student and they wouldn't know
who it was they would get called into
this big room where they would have to
decide after they get they give them
some time to look for clues who the
actual killer is and if they can't pick
the right killer than a like you know
kills like all them but in Jeff I didn't
tell you who the man with a bad guy is
so like so far you you still have some
you know faith in the series but the bad
guys you know that teddy bear that's
half black half white you see it
everywhere yeah okay by the way soul
madness says that awkward moment when
culinary out soldat occupied season two
in DVD sales well that's that is awkward
if true
so by the way it's great so how's that
check mark looks good next to your name
sir he's gone over 100,000 subscribers
recently Congrats my friend great great
job and yeah that also can someone tell
me if commentary has a second season
announced because like I said I've heard
rumors about this but it's one of those
things where wishful thinking so if
anyone knows do let me know because like
describe it I'm like man I want to watch
this [ __ ]
I can make anything sound good though
even if it's not good I could probably
have convinced you to watch tokyo ghoul
and then your great show and then you've
been all that's all I would tell them
listen Hanna Mac it's not cannibal porn
there's no it's like that's an awkward
thing to say randomly but okay but that
in the chat Lord artorias said knocks
come on your suggestions literally took
up the whole video pretty cool but let
me take the stage I don't know what he
means by let me take the stage but as
far as my recommendations I'm listing
off horror anime that no one's watched
so like there it's not really off based
recommendations cuz otherwise I'd be Joe
doing poor Anna Mac but um no but it's
true because we we made this because
it's like Halloween week I guess so
that's why we made it like obviously
Rekha fake comes two days after
Halloween but we were like it's the same
week as Halloween let's do a they should
have probably carry us into Thursday to
be honest if they will they should it
would have been more could be me
so I think that they should they should
have the crazy as though is when Howie
falls on Friday the 13th that is the
craziest Halloween's all about thinking
I love that second Friday
yeah but yeah what was it gonna say yeah
caster says that carbon Airy is getting
us into link me bro link me if you have
like an actual physical thing because
I'm interested and yeah I think we can
start to wrap it up but not Knox I do
appreciate your recommendation I think
it's good because there are a lot of
horror anime out there I think some
people would classify mushishi as horror
i wouldn't the elements that are scary
but like to me is just like us
and Jack um at least had paused on a
good face
per second like did my internet diet no
it wasn't you
sweet on it wasn't me this is good okay
I guess we're gonna have to wait for him
to come back to like wrap things up
oh and a Mac and a Mac I need you to I
need you to stutter I want me to be here
I think he's still going on cabin area
season two
this is bad okay well thank you all for
coming here end of the Halloween special
I guess it's very scary as you can see
we lost a member of the ranch cafe in
middle of the stream it's probably dead
that's it
so um yeah no way to come back to sign
us off if we want we to make it really
awkward and just leave yeah or or we
just pretend we just pretend that we're
a Mac be like oh thank you thank you for
watching I hope you all have a good day
thank you for watching Bros Bros from
knucks what do you do it how do you what
do you you to work and we find you tell
us about yourself so yeah I do I do
we just lost the host you're in charge
now I think swings well now what do you
do
Macklemore well I'm pop some tags pop
some tags I own the funny story about
how I got my youtube name locked in a
month one day Macklemore wasn't huge yet
but I had the haircut kind of before it
was a big thing and I walked into where
one day what he was becoming big two
girls are standing there they're like
wow you look like Macklemore am i oh
thank you and then they're like it
actually has
more yeah well because my name's men
real name is back I'm like well thank
you yeah my name is actually Maksim like
no yeah and then I looked at my pocket
and I'm like no wait guys guess what I
actually have 20 $20 my coincidence and
they're like they're like whoa it's like
you're Macklemore but I keep thank you
I'm not that's why it's just n ot not KN
ot you got it it's like it's not like
I'm I'm not good at tying knots
I can't I like the basic leg but other
than that it's not good hi Anna Mac
welcome please tell us what do you do on
YouTube oh yeah well that was weird
because I totally heard you guys and it
was like everything seemed normal on my
end and then apparently no one could
hear me so that was [ __ ] weird
but yeah I was nice
so did you guys wrap it up did you guys
already wrap it up yeah we just need the
Recon sniff and we're finished
so you promoted yourselves all that
stuff yeah we're amazing yeah yeah and
also black Kritika what okay yeah thank
you guys for joining us fun discussion
as always Knox and market both dudes in
the discord we're gonna have a bit of a
voice chat after party I don't know if
Lux and Matt can make it but I'll be
there in a little bit so you want to go
there voice chat hangout link is in the
description leave a like if you enjoy
ram cafe and yeah we'll keep going with
these tomorrow early morning I will have
a video out on the you a trader my hero
academia [ __ ] what what yeah I'm sure
it's further up Pocoyo me I mentioned
you know is that your stupid theory by
the way my friend Knox Taku has a stupid
theory and here's why his wrong no I did
agree the manga I know yeah
why do we read the manga because it is
only after reading the manga and getting
into the arc after
to that I actually start to enjoy boku
no here quite a bit whereas I was on the
fence and did not enjoy certain parts of
the manga at all other than anime at all
like specially the tournament arcs but I
really got into it with the villain arcs
that come after this stuff so I
definitely recommend reading that manga
narcs also anything plus I can help you
make more videos on it alright so get
stuck oh yeah me and just from a writing
perspective that's what would make the
most sense well I did mention that what
you said because I like what I do in
this video I talked about all the
suspects that I can that I've heard
about being accused of being the traitor
and then I talk about kind of what I
think so yeah it's gonna be an
interesting video tomorrow morning look
out for that and yeah discord few
minutes be there see a space cowboys